En ce moment, c’est la saison des asperges.
J’adore ce légume.
Qu’elles soient blanches ou vertes.
Le problème, c’est l’odeur que dégagent
nos urines quand on a mangé des asperges.
Ça ne sent pas bon !
C’est à cause de leur composition.
Elles contiennent un acide, qualifié très
justement d’asparagusique, qui au moment
de la digestion se transforme en composés soufrés.
Les mêmes que l’on retrouve dans l’œuf
pourri ou dans les sécrétions du putois.
Un animal réputé pour la mauvaise odeur qu’il dégage.
Ce qui est étonnant aussi avec les asperges,
c’est la rapidité avec laquelle ces composés agissent.
C’est parce que l’asperge contient
aussi beaucoup de sodium et d’eau
ce qui rend cet aliment diurétique.
Sitôt ingurgité… sitôt évacué.
Un peu comme cette « capsule de déconfiné ».
Si vous avez aimé cette capsule,
n’hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu.
Vous pouvez aussi revoir
les précédentes vidéos.
J’en réalise une nouvelle chaque jour.
Et pour être sûr de n’en rater aucune,
abonnez-vous et activez la petite cloche.
A demain et n’oubliez pas :
nous sommes confinés mais on reste en lien.
Oh, faut que je vous laisse…